[Musique]
j'aime
ça je veux bien mais ça ne te la fait
leur
apparition
très bien si les landes
quand je parle de rap retour aux sources
je parle de
faux pas être a vendu moi je sais que
j'ai une ceinture trop serré pour
comprendre huit ans c'est à dire que
quand en aucun cas ni pour de l'argent
ni pour le succès pour la notoriété tout
ça j'irai faire un rap qui est pas
propre à moi et je crois que c'est ça
qui avait avant avant les gens ils
faisaient du rap
parce qu'ils étaient ce qu'ils étaient
et que ça vous même peut-être ça
dérangeait et et ceux qui arrivent et
apprécier sa et les apprécier
aujourd'hui à des mecs ou des filles
elles vont faire du rap un peu près par
procuration quoi elles
respectent pas ce qu'ils font
ils ont un truc confort offert ça comme
ça pour que ça passe là et là pour que
ce soit perçu de telle ou telle façon et
moi je supporte pas ça et ça c'est le
rap aujourd'hui quoi il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de rappeurs qui se
commet dire je ne
sont
formatés ils sont forts maintenant c'est
pour ça que tous les pôles et à son
collègue du clonage non moi je suis moi
et tu peux pas être moi
alors que si je décide et demain de
faire du rap comme toi on se réparer
[Musique]
qui veut bien se montrer et ça c'est pas
on respire hier
[Musique]
enfin morceau s'appelle aux lobbies et
un personnel spécialement dédicacée à ma
mère et à toutes les mères des rappeurs
qui sera pas qu'elle comprenne que le
nord c'est quelque chose de bien moi
je peux entrer qu'on se tape dessus en
ce moment on est allé dans la salle et
un jardin à lui j'ai réagi comme ça
[Musique]
la ville est hyper importante à belmont
tu as vite en oeuvre
aller là bas
non merci ma mère
c'est une maman une maman surtout à mon
âge c'est important
puis elle a joué tous les rôles
c'est
quand ils ont tous l'air du père du
frère d'un sur
un peu compliquer tout le monde donc
c'était fort c'est que si mon album
c'est un peu ma vie elle fait partie de
ma vie elle est constamment là donc
c'était fort c'est qu'on le retrouve ces
deux références ta mère
c'est quoi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ça touche tout tout le monde
les adultes et jeunes les plus jeunes
encore une petit frère la 8 ans il sait
ce que c'est que le rap
passe moi j'ai grandi avec avec des
groupes comme tm dans
pendant les tympans et c'est des gens
c'est un message
donc c'est déjà il pouvait pas y c'était
comme des profs un peu ils pouvaient pas
se permettre de dire n'importe quoi
sinon j'allais faire n'importe quoi
c'est un peu ça en fait moi je les ai je
vais je les suivistes et des exemples
certes aujourd'hui pour moi le rap c'est
toujours un message
et faut qu'il soit perçu de la façon
dont tu veux qu'ils soient perçus
il faut dire des choses ça sert à rien
de faire du rap ourdir un pour rien
raconter parce que le petit de 8 ans où
le petit 12 ans il va tu écoutais mais
tu vas rien lui apporter et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe ça peut apporter
quelque chose
[Musique]